I'm cage together I'm in Microsoft
research here and I'm in a group called
Microsoft research connections and
largely deal with collaborations with
academia research organizations sort of
quite outward-facing dealing with things
like science and engineering and I'm
doing a double act with Peter here in
the lab and we're going to talk quite
broadly I think about cloud computing
and big data so we live in an
information society ok so we started as
hunter-gatherers we figured out farming
in agriculture as Danny Boyle pointed
out the Industrial Revolution changed
certainly England and the world and and
if we think about that a lot of computer
languages were developed during that
Industrial Age very much sort of
processed based thinking whereas now
with you know computer systems your
enterprise systems the World Wide Web
the internet email we're in this
information revolution and we're kind of
learning how to cope with that yeah
we're in the midst of it is hugely
exciting but when we think about
technology a lot of the technology was
not designed for this information age
and I mean information in the true sense
and so computer languages by and large
do not integrate that information in a
very nice way inside the language really
is sort of a first-class citizen and
it's very important when we think about
where we are today
both again in the consumer space where
you know with our smart phones and our
tablets and our computers we're moving
into this you know cloud world where
data is really becoming a commodity when
we think about the apps and services you
know moving towards this devices and
services world where a lot of the things
we do are based on different pieces of
information and how do we aggregate that
how do we understand that how do we
analyze that how do we present that to
the users be they consumers be they you
know people on trading desks or you know
in retail so we're
in this interesting world now where data
really is becoming a commodity and we
see that in government for instance with
a lot of the Open Data initiatives you
know like you know being spearheaded
here in the UK but also in the US and
Australia Brazil around the world where
the value of data making that data
available whether that's free over the
web making that data available
internally mashing up the internal data
so your business data with for instance
the Met Office data that's now publicly
available on the Met Office site actual
marketplace data UK and allowing
businesses and individuals to really
generate a lot more value but in order
to do that developers have to build
these apps okay they have to develop
these services and as I said a lot of
the tools and the languages we're not
really designed for this you know
frictionless movement of data from data
sources through to the end users okay
and that's a real problem a real problem
as we're in this data tsunami whether
that's in business whether it's in
science and you know I deal with you
only think about the Large Hadron
Collider we think about trying to tackle
climate change we think about healthcare
and we think about this idea of you know
monitoring disease so just just
yesterday you know they stopped an MRI
say break out at Adam Brooks by doing
genetic analysis of individuals and they
found the carrier of this MRI say and
they stopped the MRT say back outbreak
within that hospital okay and they they
staged a sequence I think 150 people
okay and now see yeah huge breakthrough
again very data-driven okay and so in
order to do this again the tools and
technologies we have not really designed
for that and so one of the things that
Andrew gave us a lovely preview of is
looking at what we call information rich
programming so how do we actually
improve the developer experience okay
and in particular here one of the
luxuries you have in the lab
Danse I'm who created this language F
sharp which is based on Oh camel so a
functional programming language which
has lots of niceness it allows you to do
very robust code very succinct
a lot of financial services are liking
this it has a unique feature called
units of measure so that you can assign
units to variables so that you can't do
calculations that are wrong because of
the units okay and they're examples
where for instance nasa lhasa mars
satellite the space shuttle did an
experiment where it flew over a mountain
they were trying to Reagan's Star Wars
program where they we're trying to
develop the laser system to shoot down
missiles and the Space Shuttle had a
mirror on the bottom of it and it flew
over the mountain and they were going to
shoot the laser to try and see if they
could have a laser hit the shuttle you
know in in sub Earth orbit and the
shuttle called down to the control
station said okay we're ready to go but
we are upside down okay and the mirror
was pointing up into space and the
engineers scurried around they scrapped
the mission and it turned out they mixed
up feet and nautical miles in the auto
pilot code okay so they had to scrap it
rerun the experiment because of unit so
f sharp has some of these most features
and the abstract language is designed
here in the lab in partnership with our
developer division in redmond and so we
can take some of these research ideas
and Don and others were thinking about
how do we program information in a
really nice way and so they developed we
developed this technology called ty
providers which are these interfaces
that we can build out to data and what
that does is it enables this what we
call intelligence for data so here we go
visual studio so what we're doing is
we're hooking to so I'm going to shoot
back to that slight there we're hooking
to one of these data sources on the web
so the World Bank publishes its data and
makes that available it has data on
every country so you know two hundred
and odd countries in the world and it
has eight thousand different indicators
for each country okay and we'll look at
that in a moment so actually that that
is over about a million and a half data
sets
okay and in order to use this okay you
can use JSON and you can go in and use
it but to give you an idea of how tricky
that is they actually have a tool on the
website which is an API builder so you
go to the thing you have to go through
the website and try and look at all the
different date thing okay what's that
data set and then it builds you the call
right to do that so your experience as a
developer is quite disjointed in terms
of okay I need to develop this app I
need this piece of information okay I
need to write the line of code I gotta
go the website go to the API builder and
you know it's quite a long winded
process so what the tie provider does is
it allows us to build a little interface
into these data sets and this is a rest
interface on the World Bank site that
and it's a few sort of hundred lines of
code and that basically unlocks that
data source okay so from within our
developer environment we can seamlessly
navigate through and that's what I want
to show you so what we've done is we've
got this DLL called sample stock World
Bank DLL so it's a piece of code that
we've compiled up which essentially
interfaces between this f-sharp language
and into the World Bank and so we create
this data so when I type data and I hit
dot what that's doing is it's sending a
request out to the World Bank website so
this is going live over the web and it's
pulling back the schema from the World
Bank into the language and strongly
typing it okay so when I do that I'm now
navigating through this web of
one-and-a-half million data sets okay
and I'm getting intellisense okay and so
I'm getting things like search okay say
United Kingdom so I've got these
indicators which are the pieces of
information and the really nice thing
that we get here is that as we come
through it's pulling back the metadata
okay so I'm navigating through one and a
half million data sets and
don't have to go and look at the
documentation I don't have to go to the
website and say oh okay adjusted net
national income searching the web pull
up the web page that tells me what it is
okay it's pulling it straight through
and again I'm getting search so GDP and
again there's lots of different types of
data in there I can do things like co2
okay this is wonderful wonderful data
source okay and again you get some quite
detailed metadata think about all your
enterprise data systems and how your
developers program against those okay
and how they're the experience they have
okay so I'm just going to do what I'm
going to do is look at electrical power
consumption so electrical consumption
per capita and I'm just going to pipe
this to the chart
hope the nice thing with f-sharp as well
this just on the side is we have this
repple so this is like Python or MATLAB
or something where I can highlight that
piece of code I hit alt enter and it
runs that piece of code and hang on I
just need to pull it across what you can
see here is the type providers gone out
pull the data back and graphed it so in
a single line of code I've navigated one
and a half million data sets found the
piece of data I want and plotted it okay
like so if I go in here so of course
what I can do that's quite interesting
so there Kyle found the dates that I
want so let's play around with that and
let's create a list of countries and
let's see what electrical consumption
looks like so you see some interesting
things and again what I've done there in
just a few lines of code is pull back
all that data and what we can see
surprise surprise yellow line at the top
any guess which country that is USA
Western Europe of the two lines in the
middle Germany in the thing I see UK and
then at the bottom what's interesting
here actually is where you can see this
sort of mini hockey stick of China
coming up at the bottom there with India
say and so I can do other things
it's a nice you know I can sort of play
around so as a data scientist or again
if you're looking at big data okay and
and John was still about you you wanted
to do your machine learning or something
this allows you to sort of navigate
through and very interactively play with
play with the data so again what's
interesting here is the co2 emissions
actually are dropping since sort of 1999
but again you can see in China you know
it's growing and so just to finish off
what I want to show is that you can then
very easily look at the correlation
between those two things and surprise
surprise your power consumption and co2
emissions are pretty much linearly
correlated so we don't really need info
on that to figure that one out but you
can imagine how easy it is to pull in
data that's just one type of ID you
could link to different system mash it
up take that puppet
push push that into and fed up there
build your machine learning algorithm so
it just provides as much nicer systems
so if I can get back to my powerpoint
and why that's important when we think
about the web is we look at how
companies are not just putting their
data on the web but they're making them
available via api's okay and at the
moment a lot and what's interesting is
you might think in an ideal world that
there would be a single standard for
programmatic API stur data on the web
okay and as with all standards this is
pretty complicated stuff and so we don't
have a standard okay so this is a
pragmatic solution which is well if
there isn't a standard let's build a tie
provider a couple hundred lines of code
and we can immediately access that API
and it's pretty much exponential in the
growth think about the way you expose
data within your enterprises okay and
how we largely we'll start doing that do
that with api's and think about that
graph for the data sources within your
particular organization
so f-sharp I showed you a World Bank
type provider which was actually written
by Thomas Patrick cheque PhD student
over the road who wrote that again in a
few 100 lines of code F sharp ships as a
product in Visual Studio 2012 and it
ships with these type providers so it
ships with a sequel type provider so you
can have that experience against any
sequel database a SharePoint will use
the O data protocol okay so you can
program against SharePoint using with
that experience we actually have a CSV
type providers quite nice you have a
spreadsheet you can program against it
so we have some things that ship out the
box but you can write your own type
provider and it's pretty easy to do that
there's instructions on how to do that
on the web but you can see how it can
unlock data and it allows you to sort of
think much more creatively and
productively about how you can make that
data work for you one of the things that
I do in my team are called connections
is we build tools for the community and
so a tool we've built is called try
f-sharp so if you gotta try sharp dog
you get a different site which was
pretty much designed to teach computer
scientists students f-sharp we're just
doing this refresh at the moment the
preview I shot dog website and if you go
in here actually you can run that demo I
showed you if you go and click the learn
button up here there's a tutorial called
data science and you can go through and
learn about type providers just through
your web browser okay and actually there
are some leaflets outside if you want to
take them and I have a bit more
information about that so so that's F
sharp so it's interesting where you talk
about big data we talk with you know
when we're out at conferences and things
we're starting with this work within
what we call information rich
programming to talk about big metadata
okay
big data employs a lot but if you've got
lots of little files or you've got lots
of different disparate data sets that
you're trying to figure out and mash
together and you know create value from
the metadata is hugely important and
when we look at a lot of the big data
solutions out there like Hadoop it
doesn't really tackle that issue from a
developer perspective
okay and so we are starting to talk
about what this work big-big metadata
there's a chap called Jim Hendler fresh
stream Hendler in the US who's one of
the big advocates for data gov in the US
he talks about broad data okay big data
big metadata broad data from different
sources lots of small data small parts
small bits of big data ok so again this
big data landscape I think is slightly
more complex than people maybe think so
another piece of work just to segue into
Peters talk we deal a lot with this
essentially Big Data in science so again
think of things like the Large Hadron
Collider think about astronomy Brian Cox
you know and the huge sky surveys okay
we did a terrible survey of the sky tera
pixel image of taking a digital
telescope image and stitching it
together okay so this idea of big data
is actually kind of permeates every
single aspect of science social science
a lot of social scientists are really
using Twitter as a tool to try and
understand the social fabric for big
data is permeating all different fields
and as Microsoft research we get a lot
people come to us saying ah can you help
us out
you know we're social scientists we're
trying to do this and so they have
symptoms they have problems they say
I've got too much data I don't know how
to access it or it's a little locked
away behind a firewall or I haven't got
the code to analyze it lots of symptoms
okay there are actions there are things
you can do so the Astronomy community
built an uber database okay for all
their data so you might get somebody
like an ecologist come ours it astronomy
they've done a great job we want to do
that we're going to spend 100 million
building ass database okay so there are
things you can do what's missing
particularly in the scientific research
field is a diagnosis tool which says
given these symptoms what's the right
action okay and so we did a project with
the University of Bath which is part of
the digital curation center in the UK
where we tried to build a model we call
it a community capability model which
looks like we call data intensive
research so some of the books outside we
have called science at Microsoft
highlight this field of data intensive
research we tend to talk about and I've
just told
about technical infrastructure okay yeah
as a techie can I like that geeky
however as most of you will know that's
that's your only problem you're pretty
lucky right economics business legal
collaboration skills and training
openness internally and externally
common practices across your
organization so what we've done is we've
built these different axes to try and
evaluate organizations research
organizations okay universities
organizations or whole disciplines that
in the middle there we're actually
putting environmental science and yes
there's a 150 million dollar project
called earth cube to pull together all
the rhyme of science in the US and
they've applied this model to say okay
where do we need to invest okay and so
we've got our website here and what's
interesting is that you could replace
that word that you can you probably
replace the word academic or something
else but replace the word data intensive
research with cloud and think about how
you're trying to think about is cloud
good for me how do i deploy cloud okay
and think about all these different axes
you need to think on so with that I'll
hand over to Peter who'll talk more
about cloud
okay so I'm the second half of the
double act and I work in a kind of
networks and economics and algorithms
area which kind of is a good summary I
think of the first parts of that I'm
interested in okay so I guess the
question is is the cloud a paradigm
shift paradigms a bit overworked word
but but I guess it as a Chinese saying
we live in interesting times and so so
Andrew gave a great quote about telling
somebody something wouldn't work there's
a big history particularly if you look
at the telephone of people saying what's
the point of that and indeed william
priests in the 19th century said the
following the americans have needed the
telephone but we do not we have plenty
of messenger boys and he's in good
company of failing to failing to see i
guess a changing environment i mean
people talk about the introduction of
the car people said what's the point of
that well if you think nearer nearer
back to the last century when when the
mobile phone was introduced and text
messaging was just a way of essentially
using simple spare capacity and who
would have thought that the finns would
use it for sharing jokes i mean that's
just a it's bizarre but that was the
dominant application at one time of SMS
so so i would argue that in fact we were
operate we're creating kind of new new
environments that create new
opportunities again this this relates to
to the telephone i used to work in the
in in networking and and so it again at
the Paris Exhibition in in 1880 they
demonstrated the telephone as a way of
listening to opera remotely people
didn't think that you'd actually pay to
talk to each other but but people went
to the theater they went to the Opera
and so they thought that the telephone
was a great way of listening to the
Opera interesting it's only now you're
sort of using the phone to actually be
able to listen to music so andrew has
talked about the connect so that connect
arose in the context of games gaming but
but it's a device that you can use as an
interface device so it's got cameras
microphones and you can use it this is
an example it's being used as a virtue
virtual reality shopping experience an
Android describe how you could use it
for 3d imaging so you can use these
things people don't if you create an
interesting capability it opens new
markets new kinds of ways of doing
things which aren't obvious and they're
not obvious to the people at the time
and I guess the great thing about the
cloud it seems to to have this to create
great cost possibilities so if you look
at standing standard kind of slides that
come out of Microsoft and marketing
slides it was the cloud about two things
about gives your agility so you can
create sort of new new experiences very
quickly and it gives you cost skates
cost savings and whether the cost
savings come from they well they
typically come from reducing total cost
of ownership
so perhaps through reducing capex or op
X costs and and so if you look at
predictions of the kind of the total
cost of ownership of running servers
then you get a you get a kind of almost
an exponential decrease the cost of
going from about a thousand service to
two hundred thousand gives you something
like an 80 percent or ten thousand gives
you something like an 80 percent
reduction in the cost of ownership and
so if you're an enterprise that means
those potential savings could be passed
on to us and in terms of the cost of
running your services so that's what
people tend to talk about but that's the
bigger opportunity to say well look what
can you do and I'd sort of argue that's
an even bigger much even bigger benefit
it's the agility but more the fact that
you can do new things that you can't do
previously so I guess I'd argue that the
landscapes changing how is it changing
well it's changing in the following ways
you're going to have you could starting
to get ubiquitous connectivity a social
network look at the values of Facebook
okay it's declining but it's still sold
for a lot of money or Groupon I mean in
this room there's something like a
hundred people so that's ten thousand
connections between if you if you just
spoke to it everybody else or there's
something like a million potential
collaborations that come out from
somebody that size so you get a huge
scale by being able to connect to
different people okay dig big date has
been talked about to death and yet as
kind of the danger of they throw
obesity you get swamped in this data but
there's a good question earlier about
well how do you know what your the
distribution looks like well if you've
got enough data in a sense the sort of
that the model starts to become less and
less him less important if you want to
estimate for example you know a
characteristic and you ask a hundred
people then your errors about something
like you know 10% error at worst case
you offer a million people that goes to
0.1% so just the scale gives you the
ability to to answer questions and get
better answers Mobile is really sort of
exploding when in the future people are
talking about the Internet of Things
suddenly the number of devices that will
be connected to it is growing
dramatically and lastly changing
economics so let's let's look at some of
those in a bit more detail so this is
the growth of mobile traffic as a
percentage of desktop traffic as you go
from 2009 to 2012 and so you can see
that in 2009 it was 1% in July and in
May of this year it was something like
10% so some like a 10 or 9 percent the
temps in growth in a number in just
three years if I was to show this on a
global scale if I just draw a map and
color the maps according to which the
percentage of mobile traffic then the
kind of Western world will mostly looks
at around this code of 10 15 bits when
the 10th if you look at India there's
the mobile traffic's greater there than
their desktop traffic and other certain
other places in Asia and they're growing
and what does that mean well it means
one thing that suddenly you've got your
got a lot more connection with people in
a mobile environment where they want
more information so I don't if you've
seen sort of some of the the latest
adverts the Lumino you can see that
there's the virtual reality type
experience when as you take a picture
you're getting information projected for
you so people are trying to work out
what is it you really want to know what
do I really want to see and those kind
of opportunities for business it explode
once you get into a mobile environment
and there's new ways of computation I
mean I think this is some of the
interest of me so later on this
afternoon people are going to talk
about computational science if you take
an example of protein folding so this
isn't it's a picture of a protein and
think of them now the way some of the
ways in which computational powers are
dressing the issue of how you work at
how proteins fold and ultimately use
that as a way of designing for example
better drugs treating people and so on
so one way this folding at home site
which is a bit like the SETI at home
site where they're using you're using
resources on people's computers to solve
to solve a distributed problem of how a
protein fold so this is kind of using a
mass so this is kind of mass computation
a mass distributed computation as a way
of solving the issue something that I
find even more appealing is this folded
type application this is essentially a
game so you can play a game and the
objective is essentially to work out how
protein folds and these have had some
kind of an interesting results that
people sitting at their computer screens
have managed to solve things that
haven't been able to be solved by using
the computational power so this these
are like games with a purpose which are
which are quite intriguing so within our
lab we've started to try out exploring
just games as a way of giving
information for example trying Facebook
games as a way of saying well how can
you how do people really react in
situations and can you learn from and
can you put that information together a
markets are changing so again if you
think of the traditional market whether
it's a buyer and seller and relatively
small in scope so the rise of online
markets and again this connectivity is
changing dramatically the way that
markets are evolving and so that all of
these are examples kind of very
different kinds of markets for example
the ad center market now you'll its
current time millions of auctions are
being held just to display an ad where
you're trying to work out when somebody
types a search query who is that person
what do they know and what they really
want to see and then if you're showing
that in a sense you're running an ad
auction to decide who should be shown
and what should be shown these are other
kinds of auctions some of these
involving sort of peer to peer or or the
Facebook type application and so on so
there's a kind of market so
changing dramatically and there's also
that I mean the others he can get
justice or amplify this kind of wisdom
of the crowd the benefits you get from
scale so the this is trying to harness
the wisdom of a cloud so one thing we
did was to go and ask people answer two
questions these were actually IQ type
questions the way you have to do some
kind of pattern matching and then from
the results you can even if you don't
know the answer you can what you you can
essentially predict what the answer is
so and the more people you have the
better the answer you get so on this
scale here's the size of a crowd in sort
of a fraction of the crowd that you use
and on this vertical scale is the
aggregate the kind of total IQ of that
sample so if you just pick a random
sample of people the average is about 1
the average IQ is about 1 you know 200
rather 100 is the average IQ as we
increase the size then then you make by
pulling the intelligence you do a lot
better and there's this interesting kind
of cliff edge effect once once you've
got relatively small percentage of the
crowd like 10% you suddenly got a kind
of a long way to getting the maximum
benefit you could you could choose so
that's four tasks where there's a very
clear answer the other thing we tried
with just to try and get people to write
an advert write an advert so that's the
case for example where we ask people to
describe a city first example where you
don't know what the kind of best advert
is so how do you do that well you can
get one group of people to write an ad
and you get another people of people to
rate it so we did both those things and
you give them kind of different
incentives so people are rewarded by how
how well other people think how good the
quality of it of the item that they
produce so this is a way of kind of a of
harnessing the power of the of the crowd
and and using data to kind of aggregate
wisdom so changing economics are lastly
to talk about money show me the money so
this this is now taking this is an
example of sales data from this is kind
of related to sales data for an online
store an online bookstore and so what I
plotted here on the on this picture here
plotted the rank in other words the
popularity of the item against the
probability that the rank is that is
things are bigger than that so for
example you know the height the the one
most popular item everything's going to
be less popular than out and so on and
I've plotted this on a log-log scale and
that shows essentially if you so this is
a straight line on a log-log scale so
this is like a per eight or Zipf
distribution so a Zipf distribution says
for example if the first items got
popularity one the second ones are half
the third the third and so on okay so
this is what the popularity looks like
and on the right hand side I've said
I've plotted the inventory size so this
is the number of items that I could like
its store and you can see again it's a
if this the the bottom scale now is the
horizontal scales a log scale and the
vertical scale is just a linear spur
centage of sales and so for example if
you take a bookstore take a bookstore
then that's got to know the best
bookstores physical is going to have
something like the order of 10,000 books
perhaps even a hundred thousand you got
to if you aggregate and so this is the
size the percentage of soil sales that
you would get from the total possible
sales if you had a books store that size
and you can see you get something like
something like 60% of the Possible's
sales if you took the total inventory of
something like two million books then
you can get all the benefit so that's
the kind of that's an illustrative
example of something like Netflix versus
Blockbuster in the video world so if you
look at Blockbuster they could only
physically hold so many items typically
typically the order of tens of thousands
now that had two effects one of the
things they affect their cost structure
their ability to sell was roughly half
their car there their costs were
approximately double out of an online
store but more importantly if you look
at if I pick a typical person in this
room and ask you what you like it turns
out that your if you in terms of your
movie preferences your book you'll like
something that's fairly popular and
perhaps you'll have something esoteric
like
mountain bike biking in at Mongolia or
something at or some nice or some weird
arts film but will you like different
things and so if you can if you Co have
this restricted inventory then what you
can offer people is restricted but if
you increase the inventory to this to
their full size the your ability or kind
of your your your satisfaction goes up
and so when the economists look at the
social welfare they said that benefits
from increasing the inventory size and
decreasing the search costs lead to
something like a Sevenfold benefit in in
in kind of consumer welfare the other
thing that's happening is code of Sundy
things are getting a lot faster so this
is just now a picture or a grid of the
time to download information in seconds
and so these for example a packet of
file something like a CD and
high-quality DVD as we as we increase
the size of our sort of download pipe
this is when we're analog so currently
then we went to DSL at a low rate and
we're currently something like in this
picture here okay and now you can
download I mean it typically you can
stream for example movie at two megabits
per second in a couple of hours it's not
a problem you can download it so that's
why online movies are starting to take
off as you go faster and faster things
kind of happen and suddenly you're
you're essentially no longer you're just
limited by essentially the time it takes
to transmit the information as a blip as
a as a packet okay and that's what this
top triangle is where's the bottom
triangle you still have to you're still
limited by the bandwidth you still got
to do some flow control so that minute
you can't quite send a music file
instantly but pretty much but soon you
will be able to the next level of DSL
you'll be able to do it and data centers
offer it operate it something like the
gigabit 10 giving it higher bit speeds
for those you can you can transfer
information almost like a packet which
kind of gives you kind of new ways of
working within a data center
okay well how'd you ask the cloud priced
well at the minute essentially if you
said so this is kind of schematic of a
something like a virtual machine it cost
something like you know 10 pence 10
cents an hour or 1/10 of a euro so these
are maximum prices these are with no
discounting essentially if you support a
really small number this is the kind of
order of magnitude what you pay what
would you pay for bandwidth will you pay
about the same amount per gigabyte so
it's getting something like 10 pence a
gigabyte in terms of if you want to
store information what's the cost well
it's about the same it's about something
like 10 pence a gigabyte if you want if
you want to manage that as a sequel and
it's a bit more and so how's how's it
price well currently you go to a website
and you kind of have to do this mix and
match and put them all together and you
come out with a cost so the problem is
if you're you know if this is you wanted
to buy this service then you have to go
out inside how much you want and and
what to ask for
I mean seems that that's a bit like
saying I want to go on a journey and the
or plain journey India and that and the
airline tells to me well you know how
how many films do you want to see how
much you weigh what how many hours
you're gonna spend eating and how and so
on we don't do those kind of things you
just want the end kind of experience
whereas in a minute this is sort of
you're having to do this kind of mix and
match put it together
which is course great so do you have to
specify a lot and there's a provider
says Microsoft as a provider the cloud
that's good it makes it easier easier
for us so the other so the problem is
that some of the other issues with this
is that this pricing is not based on any
workload at the minute and there's also
a lack of predictability so let's look
at those in a bit more detail so suppose
for example you're running a classic Map
Reduce job so the minute most jobs in
the cloud are naturally over something
like a MapReduce nature partly because
that's what the current infrastructure
looks like so in case you have a
produced job job is something where you
do a divide and conquer so think the
canonical example is something like
counting words in a document so the map
phrase is when you can you've split the
documen
up in the cetera pieces and for each
each part that you essentially count the
number of words and then the reduced
paces when you bring them back aggregate
that information together so you can
count the number of words of each
particular type and so perhaps you know
perhaps you've got this repetitive job
you're running and perhaps if you run it
an isolated cluster that it takes
something like four hours so the problem
is if once you run it in the cloud and
you're running in a data center and it
could take something like 10 to 16 hours
to run why is that difference well
partly because there's internal bandit
restrictions in the data center and
partly because there because you might
if you've got an element that's paying
per time as you are the VMS then there's
an uncertain time component so what that
means is that the the tenant costs the
variable the cost to you as a tenant are
variable and not necessarily predicted
so you might have thought the expected
cost was a hundred whatever it is
dollars pounds or whatever whereas the
actual cost could be something like two
hundred and fifty or to four hundred
pounds clearly so and so this
unpredictability of your application
performance is one of the kind of main
problems or a main problem of a current
cloud infrastructure well can you do
anything about it well let's see let's
just try some new directions so this
just left sighs Rob what Rob said I'm
not trying to sell you anything here
actually just be very interested to know
what your views are at the end and how
you think what you think about so I work
kind of in Algirdas mechanism design and
economics and so mechanism design has
the following you know attempts to
essentially say what's the best way to
design a system or again so that
everybody's happy and then toast some
desirable properties the first that
you'd want something that strategy proof
what does that mean well it means that
ideally like people to be it's in your
best interest to have people to be proof
truthful rather than have to play games
and pretend to get the best for
themselves
and if you do that you typically end up
with systems that are stable they're
efficient and they're easy to compute
and you likely to be envied free well
what does that mean that so imagine if
we divide up a piece of cake every free
means the that you're not concerned that
the person
she's got a bigger part than you have
you're happy with your allocation okay
so at the Buffy when you go out there
what you'll get your happy with that's
the means if your means you're if it's
envy free and last you'd like it to be
kind of per a Pareto optimal or at least
if your provider that's what you'd like
and what does that mean that means that
if you that if you've got this kind of
solution any change you make to it that
made somebody better off would have to
make somebody else worse off okay so
that's again it's kind of a nice a nice
property well and so one of the
consequences of this is if you need if
you want a system like this and you
cannot just do it without a liar
allowing some kind of trade or
bargaining between the participants okay
so that's the challenge
so think now of designing a system for
for example dividing up the cloud
pricing the cloud so then you've got an
issue that if you want to achieve all of
these you need to have some way of kind
of trading between people yeah well if
it's not then basically saying there's a
better place you could be with everybody
be better off
you know so I mean you you're sort of
starting off with something which is do
you know to be you can always improve on
so it's not going to be of anybody's
interest you know I mean yeah if it's
not preto optimal then everybody can be
better off okay so that's why you like
that property yeah but I mean I yes they
are but I guess they have incentives for
the users as well I mean the problem so
the issue is that if it's not strategy
proof then you have to put if you're you
know imagine you're the consumer or at
the end player you have to decide how to
plan that instance if it's not envy free
then you're seeing what somebody else
has got and you're not happy and if it's
not preto optimal that means well you
say well it could have done better by
doing this and I've got more as well so
yeah
well this one no I mean this well it's a
bit takes of it maybe this is like a mad
no I mean no basically no I mean it but
you have to get I mean there's various
theorems I mean you have to essentially
there's sort of theorems in economics
that say we if you want these properties
then you cannot just do it without with
this kind of mechanism because I mean
essentially I mean I can try and explain
in the context in trying to explain the
minute the context of a cake okay right
then so so there's there is a cake
slicing theorem it says the following if
if you want to divide it will actually
start with a quote this guy by Ludovic
might be said that a compromise of the
art of dividing a cake in such a way
that everybody believes he has the
biggest piece you know in other words
that there's Embry free and so the
interesting thing is that you can do
this you know and essentially you do it
by a version of I pick you choose and
let's say you know the classic games
there's two of you divide a cake
one person cuts the other person chooses
with lots of people you get a variance
of that but you have to start going
round and round and sort of trimming
pieces and people deciding what one they
want so to get back to your question why
can't you do all of those things so it
is very tricky to make sure that you
know that it's fair and also you think
that what the other somebody else has
got is fair so it's a means to be is
fair enough saying well I'm happy what
I've got my think this person you know
they got more than they should have and
so to avoid that that's the thing where
it gets starts to get tricky you start
to kind of almost have to say there's
some surplus and I need to divide it up
that's informally what you're doing
I mean if it was non-pro to optima list
case that you basically there's some W
me it's almost like you haven't divided
up the cake enough you know there's some
left you could divide give give that
extra to everybody so why think about
Kate
I mean why think about cakes because
them so this works I mean this
particularly works if people value
different things that people value
memory and storage differently then you
can certainly potentially divide it up
so everybody's happy and if you think of
those jobs those jobs are using
different amounts so the canonical kind
of strategies proof mechanism is the
second price auction if you're trying to
sell it good
get people to write down their bids and
you award the bid to the person who bids
the highest but you charge them the
second highest price okay if you think
about that this is something which you
then it's your best interest just to
declare your value and it's kind of
extended to add auctions so the current
adults and this is a Bing search auction
and so there's slots here if you look at
these ones at the top these are ad slots
they're being sold by a generalization
of that where you price people according
to what the person below you bids so
this actually as soon as you go beyond
the simple stage even that's not
truthful
and it certainly doesn't maximize
revenue but it's some it's a kind of
simple mechanism out there if you try
and do this in the cloud you get the
following if you're trying to run an
auction in the cloud
perhaps compare what what Amazon does
and I look at what happens if I look at
a spot market mixed with a pay-as-you-go
market okay so I'm mixing now two types
of auction I'm mixing an auction for a
spot market with a fixed kind of
predicted price if I look at the
expected revenue against various
strategies if I just offer a spot market
I just will get that but that's solid to
the blue line rather that blue line if I
just offer pay-as-you-go I get this kind
of you know the shape that looks like
this it's got this funny hump because
I'm assuming there's different users and
if I get a hybrid I get something that
looks like this black line so that's
probably a bit like Amazon doesn't the
minute so it's the interesting thing
that does it's actually if you've ever
put people in one set they get more
money if they just offered if they
didn't offer that service so that's an
interesting challenge why are they
offering it
perhaps it's partly to get people onto
the market so I guess what I'd really
like to do is we kind of go back is to
design some simple pricing scheme with
predictable performance in multiple
tenant data centers so in the systems
and networking style we're looking at
how you can predict what a job would
require and so use some notion of job
based performance or pricing in other
words I like to have predictable Network
predictable storage if I and dedicated
virtual machines and so the problem is
the well you could do that but you
potentially need to have some kind of
pricing for the different kind of items
for example virtual machines bandwidth
and and storage data and of course
there's more flavors you could do if you
had some kind of market for that but how
much should should be exposed should to
just the cloud provider worry about that
or should you is a customer should you
be involved in that do you want to
expose the kind of market mechanism so
what do you want them hidden I mean both
of those are possible there's a kind of
trade-off between flexibility and
simplicity and and information so but I
think but it's certainly we're kind of
moving to this this era where you have
will have predictable performance and
you will be able to to have rather
different pricing schemes so the
question of my question to you is kind
of you know well what what do you like
what would you like what kind of things
would you like to see okay and all there
are lender